the jurogan experience like did you see
the ufc this weekend i didn't and i
won't oh my god brian ortega
and alexander volkanovsky had one of the
craziest title fights i've ever seen in
my life it was wild and i kind of wish i
was there i i was out of town for that
one that was my hunting trip so i had to
cancel it but
god damn it was so good it was so crazy
that was a fight you couldn't
call because ortega almost won
twice with two insane submissions once
with a with a uh he got him on the
bottom with the guillotine or he
amounted him rather with the guillotine
and then he got him on the bottom with a
triangle it was insane
and ortega is known for his submission
his submissions are some of the best
he's got like
he's a torrent jiu jitsu guy right he's
from the original gracie academy in
torrance that's where i trained yeah
orion corian ran the school and his sons
you know um header yeah henry and hiron
and it's just and brian ortega came from
there a lot of it's like lineage it's
lineage like it's like some of the
purest jiu jitsu that you're gonna get
and when you say fundamentals like brian
ortega has
perfect fundamentals you know chrome
gracie
perfect perfect fundamentals they do
everything to like this razor chart when
he dove on that guillotine choke i was
like that is like i wish people could
see how beautiful that is the way i see
it yeah because i know how hard that is
to do the way he slipped it in he got
mount on the world champion full
guillotine mount our world champion and
the guy got out i mean he's gurgling
it's as deep as it gets and when you
realize how good brian ortega is and
what he's in right now he's in a mount
but he's also got his legs crossed
underneath which is like the most
ruthless mount because a regular mount
you're on top of a guy and a guy can
kind of buck bortega's got his legs
crossed so that kind of guillotine with
a guy like that is death it's death and
that crazy [ __ ] from australia
got out we're
99.9
of the people who have ever lived would
have tapped out yeah that [ __ ] savage
it's like not today [ __ ] i'd rather die
i got i did a deep dip on dig on brian
ortega
he did something good he was on
calabasas companion yes and
probably one of the most interesting
human beings i've ever heard talk he's a
actor
and his and he just doesn't come out as
an actor which is how i come at it as
like just a regular person who's an
actor he was acting before he did uh
fighting please we don't have to pull it
up no no no please let me know so let me
know hold on brian ortega was in a movie
with shia labeouf
they were both in the movie but that was
like the first or maybe he's done very
few things was that what he was already
fighting when was that moving very
recently with uh yeah but they were like
i was an extra but brian's in it but
they probably
brian because you know he's already
fought for the title before he fought
max holloway yeah he knocked out frankie
edgar i mean brian ortega has been a bad
[ __ ] for years i heard you well
i got a deep dive about him and i do i
do a thing called open tabs where i keep
all the tabs open in my safari browser
and then i do a podcast about learning
telling you about all the [ __ ] i learned
over the weekend and i had a big brian
ortega one but i took it out because
sometimes with cage fighters they don't
i maybe what i say isn't what they hear
and i don't want to piss any of them off
i know what you're saying like some
dudes are super sensitive well
i'm sensitive as [ __ ] and brian ortega
was in this movie with shia labeouf and
he said
he said he told this crazy story about
shia trying to fight him and i was like
that's hilarious and i was like is that
real
is that real yeah yeah i heard the story
so i mean
that is hilarious and so and brian
ortega the way he was telling the story
was like it was good like it was legit
good storytelling like i'm like he can
do jiu jitsu i can tell a [ __ ]
story right and the way he was telling
the story was like the way you would do
jiu jitsu
[Laughter]
no not at all actually if i knew you
just said yes he was telling it good he
was doing good watch the entire episode
for free only on spotify